hello Luca how are you hi dear
great thank you and today I'd like to
ask you some questions which are I'm
sure that they are interesting not only
for me but for a lot of people who learn
foreign languages and I know that you
can speak 10 languages right do you have
some special ability for it all you do
something particular what's your secret
well I would like to say that when
people tell me that I have a huge talent
for learning so many languages I I think
it's not necessarily true I think that
the main difference is that I know how
to learn languages I've learned how to
pick up languages effectively and and
that is that makes a huge difference
because if a lot of people make the
mistake if they think that they can
learn the language they start learning a
language the wrong way and then they
give up I don't give up because I just
found a method that works not only the
works well not only for me but I found
out it to work well for a lot of people
so I think that basically I figured out
how to learn a language in a certain way
in an effective way
right so to answer your question there
is a secret the secret is to understand
how to learn languages once you know how
to do it you can learn any language in
the world and I know that you learn all
our languages on your own and do use
traditional method or have you developed
one on your own
well it depends on you know what would
you mean by traditional method but my
method surely is not traditional in the
sense that I do things my own I have
this this method that I call the Luca
method because it's - I didn't invent it
but I just found it to be the optimal
solution for my language learning
process so the answer is yes I have my
own method to learn languages and the
good thing is that you know when you
just apply a method you you're the only
person who applies it and it works you
might think that it just applies to me
just works for me but I found found out
that it works for quite a few rated you
so
I I think that it's it's a good method
and I think that the most popular
question is how to learn you let new
words what you're holding your authority
you know learning new words is extremely
important when you try to learn a
language because it's basically
languages every language is words and
sounds and these are the two main
problems for every language learner I
think that the problem in general is
that people tend to think that they
learning less learning words by heart is
the solution so they come up with lists
of words or sentences in which they
embed these words but I learn words
indirectly it means that I figured out
that our brain works in a certain way
and I learn words indirectly meaning
that I use a certain kind of technique
which is a bi bi-directional technique
translation technique I use my own
native language to learn other to learn
words in another language I think that
your own native language is extremely
important and if you know how to use
this translation technique especially at
the beginning
you not only figure out the structure of
the network of a language but then words
are going to fall into it automatically
so you start learning words
automatically you build your net and
it's going to be easier and easier to
learn words so one main a very important
thing is not learning words by heart
this is what I never did and I'll never
do and I think everybody should avoid
learning words by heart because language
is not just an amount of words it's
about building a network of emotions and
words words come with emotions and what
are the first steps you take when you
start learning a language as I as I said
the the most important phase in language
learning is the beginning because you
find yourself in front of a huge man
and you have to know how to climate so
the first thing is I tell myself you
didn't start climbing slowly because the
path is very long and I use this
bi-directional technique so I translate
I take you know I use my own native
tongue to figure out the structure of
the of the language the foreign language
that I'm learning and I use a vibe it's
called a bi-directional technique now I
cannot delve into the details of how
this works but I can assure you that it
works quite well if you know how to do
it because it's also important to know
how to do things so first of all I use
by I use a language series which you
know it's it's very important to stress
the fact that the both day issues does
matter but what matters the most is how
to use language learning material so I
use it in a certain way in order to
absorb the information in that book can
I do this I apply a carry out this
bilingual translation and then I move on
to other things and how do you think
what are the three most important things
in learning language as I said before
attitude is very important attitude
means that the way you you approach
anything in life it is not just about
language learning a positive attitude is
extremely important for example once you
learn the basics of a language once you
can say certain things you can try just
try and use them without a problem
if you meet if you stumble upon a native
speaker you might try to speak to them
in their language even if you know a
little bit of the language itself and
you you can try to apply it in real life
because people tend to use books a lot
but I think that human interaction is
key in language learning is what really
makes a difference so attitude is very
important attitude towards learning in
general and then add it to towards
people because people are the vectors of
a language a language is is alive
because of people because of the people
who speak it and then obviously time a
lot of people complain about the fact
that now they
it's impossible to learn the language
because you don't have a time you have a
family you have other things that you
have to attend to but in general I think
that everybody finds always finds the
time to do something they like every day
and I think that if you spend some you
know if you imagine native speakers when
they are 18 they have spent so much time
learning a language their own language
and in order to learn a language well
you need a huge amount of time but the
advantages that our time is not our
enemy it's our friend if you know how to
manage time for example learning a
little bit every day 30 minutes you know
if you think about it 30 minutes is
nothing you will make a lot of progress
progress in like in it's a matter of
months not years and that's an amazing
thing and then as I as I said the third
the third factor is possibilities in
life possibilities of life means that
when you start learning a language and
you speak it at a certain level even if
you have a basic or intermediate level
what do you have to do is look for
possibilities of life and look for
friends look for people you can talk to
you look for a movie that you really
light over like a series that you really
like so you can spend time exposure
yourself to the language and you will
learn it automatically as an automatic
process so and it's not just about the
amount of books that you use it's also
the possibilities that you have a life
traveling and living in a country
getting maybe a girlfriend or a
boyfriend who speaks that language
watching something you really like in
listening to some music they really like
that makes a huge difference in the long
run thank you so much it was really
interesting see you in Moscow bye bye
thank you